alright this is Brian malarkey here we
are in San Diego California and we are
taking part in the patron secret dining
society we put together the most amazing
menu ever this is called the super
heroes of the culinary world it's about
my interpretation of the great chefs
cuisine you might wonder why we're at
the train station this is the reason the
dinner is on patron train car this is
comic-con it's all about the superheroes
the imagination running wild ority of
the most influential foodies from all
around the world Southern California all
the people that are enjoying comic-con
they're coming here and they don't even
know it we're actually gonna take him on
a scavenger hunt and this is the big
surprise this menu runs wild the
cocktails are over-the-top my very good
friend Lucien Connor is going to be
doing our cocktails all based on patron
this whole place is set up the party's
about to start but most importantly I
need to make sure the food showing up so
I'm gonna run back to my restaurant
right now so that we can have the best
food on time and ready to go
so the team is down here prepping for
this amazing dinner we're doing tonight
on the patron train we got 40 people
four courses and three passed hors
d'oeuvres
we're here we're in the kitchen we got
food let's put on the patron party we're
testing the Jean George carpaccio dish
alright so we've got extra virgin olive
oil right here lime juice little orange
segments
Jake I'm Brian nice to meet you dude hey
Jake do you like tacos oh my goodness
that's you check out the tacos on this
kid we have pickled cucumbers pickled
carrots a hoist on vinaigrette sriracha
vinaigrette ginger aioli try that one
right there let me know how that end you
then over here we have our own e
sandwich what it is we made a miso
butter miso vinaigrette and simple Unie
sea salt and some micro she show this
amazing that is amazing grace have fun
and get on out of here all right thanks
so much if the gold goal here is to get
this thing done set and moving all right
let's go my pleasure to welcome you all
aboard this evening first I'd like to
introduce to you chef Brian malarkey
he's your set for this evening I'm super
excited to be on the train what way to
honor a lot of chefs that have been very
influential in my life we're going with
our crudo plate which is John George and
then we're gonna do a little Julia
Child's inspiration and then asked avi a
of course Lucien what to say something
you're gonna see a lot of sort of
different things that were playing with
tonight I want to do highlights of
different fun sort of dramatic Supergirl
as techniques you saw this factor with a
little liquid nitrogen I think we really
are going to have some fine pairing with
chef Brian malarkey spoon so enjoy the
train ride kids and thank you all so
very much and I'll see it a little bit
she there really beautifully with the
cocktail you're having the poison ivy on
this cocktail is a combination of just
fresh lime some of patrones wonderful
tequila a little bit of sugar and Omaha
Santa sacred leaf very light refreshing
should go great piece yeah this is a
very very unique dish and I would like
you all to close your eyes and eat it
with your eyes closed you know how they
say that food is all senses avoid the I
sense on this one for you get rid of all
B's and flaws clean tables clean tables
clean tables it's going fast all right
guys let's get this out of here twist on
an old fashioned this is just a really
amped up tequila cocktail this is our
Ascot be a dish very rich very classic
and very fun with the filet mignon nicer
seared mushroom on top with the Oregon
summer white truffle shaved on top you
guys this has been a lot of fun enjoy
the rest of the train ride we'll see you
inside thank you thank you thank you
it is our first dinner on a train and I
thought was fantastic first time in the
dining car club it was wonderful and it
was so interesting just to see his
process in the way that he worked with
the other people in his kitchen tours
kitchen it was just outside on a train
platform and it was just amazing to see
them all work together and how fluid it
was it was really cool the glass is
finally half full it was an incredible
journey there was an incredible train
ride we had a good time that people love
the food the people loved cocktails most
importantly the train arrived safely